this is the theme the bismillah hum
today da Salaam alaikum peace be unto
you how many a host and you are watching
the D show thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the Deen show we have
another person's story so many people
this is a phenomenon so many people are
coming to Islam they're realizing you
know what this life is going to end soon
I better get with it I better figure out
what the purpose of life is and my next
guest figured out what the purpose of
life is and what he needs to be doing
while he's here and this earth and we're
going to hear his story story coming up
next sheikh abdul-hakeem quick here on
the D show you don't want to go
this is the
Abdulla Hakeem quick on the Dean show
back again yes sir now you have your own
private section you know that the Dean
so that calm people can go there they
can read your bio and they can see the
other program that we did with yourself
talking about the holidays where they
originated from but today we're gonna be
talking about your unique journey to
Islam used to be a Christian and I hear
Muslim when I was chosen to consciously
submit to the one God worshiping him
alone and not what he created let's talk
about your life before Islam how did
this all start okay Smila man rahim
allah sawas solo about I was born in
Boston Massachusetts right northeast
corner of the United States and
hamdullah my family was a good
hard-working family my father was a
welder used to go high up on buildings
and my mother was a very religious
person and the Christian Church so I was
raised with good values and I would
attend the church and we were
Episcopalians that's very close to
Catholic so we had communion and you
know different rituals that are very
similar to the Catholic Church but as a
young man and we were living at that
time in Cambridge which the section of
Boston we are having MIT s there was
sort of a class stratification within
the church itself and I could feel the
pressure of you know being part of a
society where I was being I was left out
and I started to question things and
this was the 60s and the 60s was as you
know a turbulent time in America it was
the Age of Aquarius as they said people
were questioning their identity
questioning religion and as a young
person I believe strongly in the creator
and I used to pray the Lord's Prayer
constantly and
you know I had a solid belief in God but
I couldn't accept the image of Christ's
the way they depicted it because I used
to study history a lot yes and I knew
that the people living in the Middle
East you know had a different appearance
than that than Jesus and they were
saying that this is God or the Son of
God and then putting an appearance upon
him that was not Middle Eastern then in
the communion itself they they they had
rituals where we were eating the body of
Christ and drinking his blood and things
like that and these are some of the
rituals this isn't a communion where
they give you the wafer and they say eat
this this is the body of Christ that has
been shed for you and then you drink the
little bit of why and they say drink
this this is the blood of Christ that
has been shed for you so when the thin
wafer and the blood come together it's
almost down it's like skin it tastes
like a piece of skin with blood on it
yeah so so you get the sensation that
you have human flesh in your mouth and
blood and I said this is not the
religion I mean I read about vampires
and you know this type of culture and I
couldn't associate that with the the law
of Moses what do G Jewish people were
doing because you know within the Jewish
tradition there's nothing like this yeah
and so I was having a problem and then
you know even the rituals of the Easter
celebration and Christmas and you know
the connection you know with
nature-based things and so I was
confused you know at a young age and I
left the church so what age were you
when you left the church at that time I
was about 17 years old so you were doing
you're a young man doing your homework
yes I was doing my homework and I was
studying and I was fortunate you know we
lived in a you know the three-story you
know housing tenement you know which was
in Cambridge in between big universities
but in our community center the students
used to come and to the RUS so we had
access to knowledge if I used to you
know do a lot of questioning
reading National Geographic reading
history books you know to try to find
out what was outside of the United
States and this really you know I think
gave me that you know broad look you
know that that that you know spurred me
on you have to look beyond you know the
narrow teachings that I was finding
within the church we hear that today a
seventeen year old to be discussing or
looking into religion the way you were
at seventy word was this prevalent at
that time or more youth more inquisitive
I wouldn't say it was prevalent but may
you know within this particular
community center there are a number of
very enlightened students who wanted to
pass off information you know to the
children of the ghetto so to speak and
so you know our minds met and I was wide
open
and so on we had access to international
affairs and also to history books we
could question you know we could put it
together and so this is what gave me
this worldview from an early age and and
as I was studying I ran into the image
of Sultan Salahuddin Liu P Rahim a whole
lot he is the famous Muslim leader of
the Crusades and even the Christians
when they looked at salahuddin they
looked at him you know as a very kind
and merciful person a noble person a
dignified person didn't they make a
movie is like yeah they were making
movies I mean it's only recently that
they came up with a very important movie
on salahuddin the kingdom of heaven you
know and then that one has got you know
shows him but I was really looking at it
from a historical point of view you know
you know and what they were talking
about the Holy Land you know and I was
anxious to travel to the Holy Land and
you know to see this you know this this
image of this person and the people he
represented because in the Islamic world
you know was not clear to us we were
never given an image him it was exotic
it was Ali Baba and the Forty Thieves
Aladdin in the lamp
you know Open Sesame and thousand and
one Arabian Nights but we didn't have
access to what it was so I was yearning
to find out Tom you know plus the fact
that I you know I
I have an african-american I'm searching
for my roots you know when I see in West
Africa also great heroes and great
leaders jocose Mandan podium Sokoto
Mansa Musa the great emperor of Mali in
all this at this young age of 17 at this
young age 17 18 you know I was I was a
good student in school to the kids and
tennis or just stuck on the Xbox and the
TV and and all these other things you
are at 17 if you were able to do it they
can do it too that's right because even
with the Internet itself Internet ism
you know not just for sport and play but
with an internet you know you have a lot
of information so so you know these
different forms of technology are only
tools that we can use to benefit
ourselves when I was young we only had
National Geographic and you know things
like that you know some sort of our
documentaries and films and you know so
we had to go to film libraries and yeah
you know read you know special books in
order to get this information so let's
back up just a little bit forward you
know for so you believe that Jesus you
said you believed in God but now there
was some of these rituals you weren't
identifying with you were studying
history things weren't adding up wasn't
making sense
did you believe before that the Jesus
was God they died for your sins this was
a problem for me you know I believe that
people were sinful but but for me the
most powerful image of creation was the
creator and when you read the Lord's
Prayer
you are saying our Father who art in
heaven hallowed be thy name
so you're speaking to the father to the
Creator the one guy the one God so for
me because in my area was a mixed area
there was black Spanish white we were
living together you know and so on that
there's a one God who's above all of us
and and you can't take a face of a
certain image of a certain race and say
that's God because all of us are the
children of God so to speak so I
couldn't accept that you know the image
of a man and I was searching for you
know a bigger concept you know of God
and I was making my Lord's Prayer and
and then searching anything so I left
the church you know and I searched the
Lord's Prayer and we're gonna end with
that we come back with more
back here on addy show I'm doing I Keane
quick and we left off with it it just
wasn't fitting it didn't make sense
you're saying the Lord's Prayer praying
to the one god this is something that it
just goes with what's intrinsically
inside you isn't it that's right don't
do you find that most people they have a
problem with this but some people just
overlooking and then just you know
sliding in and Sunday just going with
the flow of don't even question it yeah
question yeah most people accept you
know the dark mother did the rituals
that this is just the church you have to
do it whenever you question we were told
it's a mystery and so we're not sure
what this mystery is but I said no that
there's got to be an answer so the
mystery Sherlock Holmes you know was
solving all kinds of mysteries man so
why can't I solve a mystery yeah you
know and so this is really what the
search yeah you know let me you know -
and then I traveled out you know in
university I was in Pennsylvania first
and I went to Reed College and Portland
Oregon so I was on the west coast in the
60s and that was a real turbulent place
things were going off and we formed a
black student union you know we wanted
you know to have African Studies and in
the university we struggled for it and
we were actually given you know a Black
Studies program but this you know I was
still not satisfied with what I was
getting and I left the university or
your parents concerned
did your parents try to have you or did
you go to try to talk to someone of
knowledge and to have a dialogue and ask
these tough questions yes I mean I was
you know going to different religious
leaders Buddhism Hinduism forms of
Christianity I even ran into people from
the Nation of Islam you know and you
know I I attended the Nation of Islam's
you know center there you know in
Portland Oregon but but that was not
satisfying to me either because I was
raised in a mixed area so I couldn't
accept the supremacy of one group over
another whether it's white or black or
black / white
this is the nation now that was the
nation of a [ __ ] so even that did not
satisfy me because our date now
worshiping another man yeah so they were
worshiping a man and then they're also
talking supremacy yeah you know and so
that didn't satisfy me either which
Islam is totally erratic and of course
no racism whatsoever that's right the
real Islam yeah it's something different
but I hadn't found that yet yeah so I
left the university went back home and I
was drafted because this was the Vietnam
War yeah and again I was I had access to
information and so I checked out the
history of that part of the world and I
had you know you know some information
about what was really going on and I
said no I mean I'm not gonna go over
there and then fight people you know who
have never done anything to me I mean I
don't understand this but we were still
suffering with civil rights you know the
struggle was going on people were being
you know murdered great leaders
assassinated you know why should I you
know get involved in this so I was
drafted and I decided that you know
instead of being involved in the
confusion at the time I would just leave
in search of knowledge so I left the
United States and I went to Canada you
know as a war resistant and I you know
was welcomed here in Canada and but as I
was moving away from confusion and war
and I ran into Islam yeah so back back
it up so you just you didn't want to go
hurting people you wanted to live your
life seek truth be a good human being
and you just didn't feel like hey this
is the right hand go kill somebody
that's right
poor people going to kill poor people
that's right I mean why you know get
involved in something like this you know
it doesn't make sense it wasn't
explained properly and again I had
access to people from Harvard University
and from MIT
you know the anti-war movement was very
powerful in Cambridge at the time so I
had access to you know information that
many of the the youth coming out of the
you know black community you know did
not have access to weren't like Muhammad
Ali
Martin Luther King they were kind of
doing the same thing yes they were so so
there was a certain level within the
society generally on the lower level
where I was coming from
you know people submitted because nobody
even thought about leaving home because
the United States was the world we would
call it this is the world you know we
don't speak another language you know we
don't have access to other information
except you know Superman and Superfly
and the things that are given to us you
know so now I decided to move because I
was reading National Geographic going to
the documentary film you know programs
you know so I left the United States
went to Canada and started a new life
yeah and it was here in Canada you know
that I you know ran into the teachings
of Islam I went to a library and I
picked up a copy of the Koran and then I
began to read it in the life of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and I
said no this was the person out that I
was looking for you know she also okay
we covered Christianity but you've
mentioned some other religions you also
did you looked into Buddhism and
Hinduism some of these other world
religions right sort at the time you
know on Reed College campus this was one
of the experimental colleges like
Swarthmore and Oberlin and Antioch you
know so so on that campus there's a lot
of like you know different you know New
Age religions and whatnot so I was
reading into them and trying yoga and
meditation and whatnot and but it didn't
really satisfy because it wasn't giving
me a worldview it wasn't connecting me
to the creator because I'm coming out of
a judeo-christian background yeah
so these religions didn't really satisfy
what I was looking for so you had
checked up looked into investigated all
the different major religions and it
just didn't provide the logical rational
scientific evidence
now we come to a slow what happened now
when I came to Islam and I realized that
this is an extension and the completion
of the of the great religions of
monotheism
this was answering you know my my
questions you weren't blindly obviously
from your investigation as a 70
you know you were analytically
scientifically logically you're an
intellectual you were looking at this
from an intellectual perspective that's
right yeah so now the Islam capture you
in that way
so then you know this is where the
interest came yeah but what it was that
the example of the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon me how he lived and how he
treated other people he had all
different nations around him here you
know that the concepts it was it made
sense to me I had stopped eating pork I
wasn't drinking alcohol you know I was
trying to live a decent life although I
wasn't a Muslim yeah you know and so I
was looking for something that would you
know give me that worldview would you
know talk about my own roots you know
connect me to the creator and then give
me a lifestyle and so I found all of
these things in Islam I had a lifestyle
I had a dietary plan I had a way to
conduct my marriage everything in a way
to raise I was a package in Islam it was
a way of life from A to Z from A to Z so
that's worth so so this that that that
was what I wanted Wow unfortunately uh
you know I met I was taken by some
friends from Pakistan I asked him about
his family said no go to the center and
there was a very well-known person
dr. Hameed sapa who's a famous Lebanese
you know doctor from America who was up
with the Muslim Student Association and
so I sat with him and he convinced me
and he gave me Shahada homes and I
became so would you go get dipped in the
back of a pool what happened dog
wouldn't you do something weird what was
it that you became a Muslim and you said
some you know Arabic terms now you said
you took a Shahada you became a Muslim
you defined these yeah basically the
procedure is I mean once you know the
person sees where you're coming from and
you know he saw that I believed in one
God yeah I was searching for the One God
so this is a moon down in Arabic I know
this is not the moon god this is the
Creator that the God of Abraham Moses
Jesus you know Adam all the prophets
from the beginning of time
that's the God that
Jesus prayed to that's the God Jesus
pray to Moses prayed to Abraham prayed
to Adam the first man prayed to that all
of the prophets and that I had I was
familiar with the example and life of
the Prophet Muhammad bin Abdul Allah
peace be upon him from Arabia and I
could see that he was the fulfillment
he was the comforter he was the one that
Jesus was speaking about that Moses was
speaking about and so I had these two
aspects and basically our dr. sucker you
know showed me that that means you are a
Muslim you are Muslim and we're gonna be
right there to find out more of this
exciting story on the right back there
always be someone that will be there to
say something negative but at the same
time there'll be someone there to say
something positive also just hold on to
the Rope of Allah everything in this
universe can rely a needle of the Quran
says don't kill women don't kill
children don't feel old people don't
attack the civilians this is what the
Prophet Muhammad told us
if a emotional law said that the prophet
saww solid never ever stopped a war
existing you're a Muslim now so from
there basically without any major
ritualistic process you know I incident
to Islam and it was about knowledge and
you know gaining this lifestyle now
fortunately for me it was right before
Ramadan and this is a test but I was
serious you know who was two days before
Ramadan so I went back to you know my
apartment and I learned to read the
opening chapter of the Quran al fatiha
you know I got my basic you know
movements together and I went to the
Masjid you know the first day Ramadan I
start fasting right away so I fasted and
I went to the to the Masjid and they
took me to the Jami mosque and they
prayed twenty rare cups no I used to
play basketball I used to wear like leg
weights on my legs and you know so my
knees right so after about the twentieth
Burkhard I said like if this is Islam I
don't know if I can make it better I
don't know if I can handle this yeah if
this is what you know these people do
you think this is fanatical yeah this is
they said no brother this is Ramadan
here you have your choice so this is now
running down this is can you explain for
our viewers why was so many this urges
yeah that this is now a special prayer
in the evenings of Ramadan so dr. Todd
are we and this is the prayer of the
Prophet Mohammad peace be upon him
because it was a special month he used
to make special prayers in the jame
mosque with his followers and of course
it was you know a prayer of relaxation
this is what tada we is giving us from
raha so it's a prayer of relaxation so
the idea of that many rakaats you know
is that you're really reading the Quran
and you're living with the verses you
know not something that you know makes
you tie it yeah
and so the brothers explained to me that
no you don't have to do the 20 take your
time you do what you can do and this is
a special prayer in this month so once I
realize that then I got a balanced view
of ya
Ramadhan alhamdulillah at the whole
month I was very serious you know by the
end of the month I had learned to make
my prayers understood the basic
foundations you know and then I was you
know ready to go like a horse yeah yeah
you let him out he was feeling it yeah
you know the change had come over my
life the worldview was there and now I
was ready to see the world and to travel
you know with this new understanding and
this new Brotherhood I I had latched on
to you know really opened up the door
for me to be able to travel to other
parts of the world now you know the
question was answered in this verbatim
word of the other program
clear yeah what you were doing in his
life from A to Z your blueprint
instruction on how to live everything
was clear
yeah ambiguity okay you know when you're
coming into any new way of life there
are some things that are not totally
clear yeah and so this is where
knowledge comes in okay so really you
know a person coming into Islam it's
about seeking knowledge and it's about
learning this lifestyle because when we
used to pray you know as Christians we
didn't do a complete physical prayer we
prayed spiritually and mentally you know
so now there's a physical prayer there's
a movement you know it's it's a complete
prayer of the prophets you know when we
used to fast you know you don't need
fast for meeting meet or something like
that in Lent and you know certainly we
didn't do the complete fast now it's the
complete fast when we used to give
charity you know we would give to the
poor but it wasn't an institutionalized
form of zakat or charity or poor do you
know which really you know is it's
changing your whole attitude towards
your money yeah toheeb the oneness of
God now you know I had to learn what it
really meant all the aspects of the toe
heat pilgrimage I had to prepare myself
to travel you know you know to the east
you know to really go to the holy Lance
so now this is a change that you have to
go through and but for me you know I was
open I was ready you know
I was willing to you know investigate
things by you know you know my mind was
set and so it was easy for me to meet to
make the change you know into a slow
excited hearing this the viewers are
excited we're going to take a break so
your journey is getting excited as you
go along is even more exciting you're
learning and you're starting to
implement the way of life of all the
prophets Islam what goes on from here so
from here I run into Muslims who are
involved in the Sunda they say it's the
Sunnah yes I say what is this wonder
they say okay there's a different
lifestyle in the sense that year you can
eat so you learn to eat sitting down
with your hands you you wash yourself
and you know you're wearing loose
clothing you know and you know the way
that you relate to people you know a
humble way but strong way you know some
learning this Sunnah which is the
lifestyle of the Prophet Muhammad SAW
some of them can you translate how do
you track the way yes you could say that
the methodology and the lifestyle and
the way of the Prophet can you if you
link this back to Jesus's time Moses
this time those people following them
were they on the Sunnah of their prophet
at that time the way exactly because
really the Prophet is the one who he's
the example and so his life exemplifies
the book itself and and that's what the
Sunnah is it is bad it is the clear
evidence of the book so the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him has described
by his wife Aisha may Allah be pleased
with her
he was the court head walking and
talking
so he was the living book and so this
now when you start to implement the
Sunda in terms of you know your
lifestyle now it's changing your
lifestyle you know and and so this Psalm
is important because by changing your
lifestyle how you move you're able to
leave the boxed in American culture and
then travel to other cultures because
the one thing consistent you know for
Muslims all throughout the world you
know is this practice of the lifestyle
based on the Quran and the Sunnah so you
can go to China you can go to India
South America Africa Europe wherever and
you'll find somebody who's on the same
lifestyle you pray together pray
together there's nothing like you go to
this mosque or this place of worship and
they're reciting something totally
different
everything is unified the same praying
in the same direction that's right the
Arabic language being used you know and
and and you know even the way that
people relate to each other meaning you
can tell that a person you know is a
Muslim because you know they're there
did their humble with you and they give
you your limits you know they know the
limits you know whatnot and you know so
there's a certain air about a Muslim
who's practicing and that's something
you know that that you can find all over
the world you know so I was adapting
coming out of a rough street type of
life you know and now being refined
because being Muslim is is really like
what we would call it's it's being noble
yeah it's really noble man it's it's
high character so it's worshiping the
one God and developing your character to
be the best human being that you exactly
so so so this really was a stage of
development for me which was very
important and I went through this
fortunately in Toronto at the time had a
very large immigrant population so there
were people from different parts of the
Muslim world who were here and I
interacted with them and I began to
learn this lifestyle you know and
started looking towards you know the
East in a sense to go to the Holy Land
and you know to learn Arabic and to
learn more about my faith this is
amazing because you
we are from being a Christian
experimenting looking at all the other
world religions you came to know that
this was the truth from the creator of
the heavens on earth and you became an
Islamic scholar and there's so much more
we need to talk about would you agree to
continue in another program the rest of
your story
definitely all right so God willing
we're going to do another episode next
week join us where we continue sharing
the shared experience on how he came to
us on thank you may God Almighty long
reward your service and thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the D
show same time same Channel next week
for the rest of this exciting story
we'll see you then
Sabich and peace be unto you he created
the universe to him alone the heavens
and the
he is the first he's the ponderously
eat them his messengers to all these
creatures of the great dangers
worshiping Allah then Allah there is
none greater create there is none
greater
Oh
Oh